hier soir nous évoquions une interview
qui avait donné le chanteur jean lui
plaît dans l'émission welcome magazine
live une interview dans laquelle
l'artiste revenu sur sa vision du
confinement moi je joue au quasi
normalement
le confinement je considère que c'est
une immense supercherie et ça nous ça ne
regarde que moi ça n'engage que moi
avant d'en dire plus sur son quotidien
je vis ma vie je sors en bécane je mets
un masque parce que voilà oui je suis je
je je je joue le jeu du masque
mais point barre sinon ça ne m'empêche
pas de sortir devant mes potes et voir
les enfants
il précise qu'il ne peut plus non plus
faire de parachutisme mais uniquement
parce que son club est fermé
un discours à total contre courant de la
période qu'il assume et revendique
pardon pour ce qu'ils sont qui veulent
rester dans le cadre j'ai ma gym qui y
en a bon moi j'ai toujours fait de du
hors piste dans ma vie et m'obliger à me
restait à rester enfermée chez moi c'est
impossible
il vaut mieux mettre en prison ceux
comme à son habitude jean luc lahaye ne
mâche pas ses mots et marchent contre le
vent un discours singulier qui a
beaucoup fait parler
ce soir il était avec nous en direct
dans ce soir chez ba ba pour nous en
dire plus
et oui jean luc est avec nous merci jean
luc lahaye d'être avec nous merci jean
luc bien fait mercher et jean-luc quoi
quand même et il est il est quand même
il est frais franchement je sais pas ce
que tu fais jean-luc mais franchement tu
tues tu gardes tu garde la forme en le
confirmant que veux tu tu doutes je re
tennis ou pas abracadabra avant le
confinement des mets toujours au tennis
ou pas non je fais je fais beaucoup de
passes réussies à web ça fait maigrir le
parachutisme parce que je vais me mettre
si l'on pouvait lire pas bien tu es le
bienvenu à mon club de frais toile
château combattre ouvrir un débat très
bien jean luc lahaye va nous expliquer
et valoir son droit de réponse
aujourd'hui
jean-luc face à à nos chroniqueurs vous
restez avec nous on se retrouve dans
d'un instant dans trois minutes
exactement
jean-luc y est c'est vrai qu'on a vu cet
extrait où tu étais en facebook live
outils disaient certaines choses ou tu
disais que c'est vrai que tu avais dit
que voilà je voulais vivre dans les rues
de paris avec ta moto que le confinement
et est une supercherie et c'est vrai que
le plateau hier s'est enflammé et
aujourd'hui on voulait donner un droit
de réponse
bah déjà merci d'être là jean luc déjà
ça n'est fait nous fait bien plaisir la
lampe est sûre surtout ce que sur tout
ce que tu as dit est-ce que tu tues tu
veux run tu veux redire ce que tu as dit
où est ce que tu veux dire voilà tu leur
préciser les choses sur ce que tu as dit
sur l'empilement etc
alors bien sûr on a prêté des mots et
des intentions qui n'étaient pas les
miennes je n'ai jamais dit que je
roulais vite dans paris j'ai dit que je
roulais à une certaine vitesse ce qui ne
veut pas dire vite non plus d'autre part
je voulais préciser que je respecte le
confinement
je le respecte et je suis bien placé
pour respecter le corps médical pour des
raisons personnelles mais je respecte le
corps médical eux et ensuite je voulais
dire ce que j'applique les consignes
lorsque je sors à moto c'est je remplis
mon attestation et je me rends visite à
une de mes filles pour des raisons
particulières
chaque jour alors hein je suis très
précoce mieux je roule à moto certes
jamaïque je suis gants pour masquer et
même lorsque je vais dans un commerce je
ne retire pas mon casque je respecte les
les distances que l'on colle au que le
l'état concert à conseiller et lorsque
je vais voir des potes
c'est en fin de journée lorsque je veux
faire deux trois achats on s'arrange
pour être dans le même quartier c'est à
dire à montbard à peu près dans la file
d'attenté des mêmes boutiques et on se
parle quelques mots mêmes jose parfois
on est un thermos avec du thé au lait et
on s'échange des gobelets sans boire
dans le même est-ce que ça c'est pas
prendre des précautions
alors alors valérie était assez remonté
hier contre jean-luc qui est vraiment en
plus voilà quel courage de venir ici ce
soir pour nous faire nous re re préciser
son propos qu'est ce que tu as bien moi
je suis absolument ravi de vous entendre
dire que ça jean luc lahaye ben c'est
effectivement vos propos hier - la tête
que je les ai reçus et c'était pas des
on dit c'était ce que vous disiez passe
caméra de moi je les écris tel quel je
vous ai entendu dire effectivement que
ça ne me concerne et que vous l'avez de
conséquence ni personne d'autre
moi ça m'a fait bondir de mon siège bien
évidemment maintenant je suis à la
maison
oui j'ai maintenant je suis extrêmement
heureuse de me répéter les gestes
barrières que vous respectez les
consignes de confinement
voilà alors il faut avoir un écran on va
devoir
on va voir l'extrait on va voir
l'extrait qui a énervé valérie bénaïm
voilà qu on appelle où est charlie dans
l'équipe avec ses lunettes
regardez regardez regardez cet extrait
il y avait hier valérie bénaïm de
jean-luc regardez moi qui je suis
quelqu'un est pris de libertés
totalement je considère que ce mot
engage un contrôle permanent de nos
déplacements
c'est comment comment le dire si c'est
un mot générique qui ne déplaît pas être
confinée d'aborder en deux mots c'est
encore pire qu'on finit même on a l'air
de confier
non non moi je ça me déplaît énormément
ce ce principe des plaies ce mot alors
je le jeu l'excellent m'obliger à me
rester enfermée chez moi
c'est impossible il vaut mieux mettre en
prison au sud c'est vrai que le mot
confiné ce sera le mot qu'on aura le
plus entendu un cette année ça c'est sûr
et certain avec ovi 2009 et coronavirus
un oui valérie benaïm non mais si vous
vous rendez compte avec la effectivement
que on a l'impression de tonnerre
d'applaudissements ya le discours qu'on
a entendu hier et qui moi je le redis me
fait bondir
et me met vraiment pardonnez-moi met
hors de moi et levis pour aujourd'hui je
vous tenez qui a un discours que moi
auquel j'adhère
et donc voilà on est un peu en mesure de
ce tir les attendait le cas les deux
évoqué alors même jean-luc je maintiens
ce que j'ai dit que le confinement mais
profondément désagréable jeu le match je
le fais et je jeu là dessus je suis chez
moi
23 heures par jour mais ça met
profondément désagréable il considère
excusez-moi fin langage que moi une fois
de plus que c'est une atteinte à ma
liberté
moi qui mets libre jeu régulier de j'ai
fugué de quatre familles d'accueil pour
dormir dans des trains dans des gares
dans des bouches de métro pour être
libre toute mon enfance
et aujourd'hui je me vois obligé de
rester chez moi de remplir une
attestation pour justifier mes
déplacements jamais désagréable mais je
me plie et je joue le jeu alors on
imagine mon run et je suis quand même
libre de dire ce que je pense que rené
rené oui voila moi et moi je veux bien
qu'il ait vendu petit prince mais comme
le dit valérie hier tu gères tu es mieux
nitoo contout top
ce qui m'a mis hors de moi c'est qu'elle
tue à abbey moi j'ai toujours fait du
hors piste
mais c'est vrai une bille de rebelles
comme un moyen de passe de mener une vie
de papa sow mais chaque endroit
je n'ai jamais mis en danger d'autrui et
là que tu me dis moi le confinement
j'exècre ce terme mais on est tous les
consignes et de france et de navarre
admettre marché bon c'est même si bien
sûr on est d'accord
alors alors jean-luc ce que tu as
fallait dire en fait ce que tu as voulu
dire c'est que tu respectes le
confinement mais que tu ne supportes pas
comme l'ensemble de la population qu'en
fait enfin le langage jeu mais je
voulais dire un petit mot
et melvil c'est bâle ville mais tout le
monde l'appelle melville également fait
que tu peux l'appeler rendez vous vous
dites rebelles shirley eux
ok alors vous devriez davantage vous
inspirer de cette phrase de du grand léo
ferré que j'adore qui a dit que s'il
vient ton perdant dans la morale c'est
que c'est toujours la morale des autres
alors le vrai rebelle
ce celui qui se révolte contre
l'autorité d'un pouvoir étendu dès lors
c'est là mais là où jeanne mois je
retire la décision gouvernementale pour
une crise sanitaire ou l'abus des deux
mortels d'alary et la remettre aux
blacks dieu sait si j'ai j'ai toujours
été contre l'autorité mais la cible
obligations à leur place on en crève ont
été crevés les nôtres je veux dire
aujourd'hui rené rené cet art rebelle
il va même contre l'avis de son coiffeur
pour te dire c'est quelqu'un je mange ce
qu'il fait dérober lyon à tout moment
mais non mais non mais rené c'est vrai
creux dessin rebelles mais là il dit un
truc qui est vrai on est là il dit un
truc c'est que il dit ils se rebellent
quand il faut voilà quand c'est pour le
bien de la population mais là là là là
pour le bien de la population pour
rester chez soi pour rester confiner ces
décisions gouvernementales mais que pour
le bien de tout le monde c'est pas une
décision gouvernementale pour nous un
milan pour nous punir c'est ce que tu
veux dire mon run est d'accord bon ça
c'est l'humain c'est parce que comme je
t'ai dit cyril mois ou sur le gosse
d'être là ça me fait chier a bien sûr
empreinte gravement malade et il ya tout
à l'heure à ben ali et qui a parlé des
personnels de soignants un fût celle ci
je leur suis reconnaissant à lisser ces
deux marchés
comme ils soignaient monclar mais je
leur ai bien hâte à côté de revoir et
bien je ne peux pas y aller je peux pas
faire plus de sa borne et lui ça fait
dix ans qu'il a la même maladie que le
boire mon bord bernard tapie voilà
d'accord elle va très bien mais va très
bien vous voyez c'est regrettable et
c'est bien triste
j'ai la chance moi a ajouté paris de
pouvoir rendre visite à une des mes fils
journalièrement et je remplis mon
attestation et je plains les gestes de
précaution et je respecte le personnel
médical
je ne mens pas de réponse toujours
présent lorsqu'on me demande de faire
une prestation un concert pour lever des
fonds pour les autres
je le fais tout le temps dès que je peux
et je vous rappelle que j'ai créé mon
association et d'apprendre qu'après
siens je vais lever plus de centaines
des centaines d'enfants et j'en fais pas
une ni tambour ni trompette et un jour
tels les louves la légende romaine de
remuer romulus et rémus et romulus mes
filles viendront prendre le relais à moi
et je fêterai j'en fais pas j'en fais
pas état dans tout dans tout l'est dans
tous les journaux tous les magazines
rené est ce que l'art est ce que
l'arrivée de jean-luc te tiens oui mais
voilà la chose qui m'a déplu
cet effet expression tordus en piste un
pas que justement les gens les people
communiste super connu il reconquiert
dada c'est moman parce que même moi
c'est d'être là j'ai jamais connue aux
membres et bien les gens il faut pas
parler de faire du hors-piste fatigue ou
paix aux côtés de niro resteront là
[ __ ] de merde voilà et ne pas dire
j'adore l'art de l'artiste voilà je
parlais de mon mode de vie
quand je parlais de ce monde de liberté
que j'avais en ce moment - qu'ils ont
fait du rift je me trouve un peu étriqué
dans cette situation il convient de
blessés qui sont compilés les français
comme des cornes on me pose la question
je réponds bah là ok donc au niveau
radio jura dit gerald moi non mais c'est
vrai moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec avec votre cri avec rené sauf si
vous viviez ou à moins de vivre sur une
île déserte on est dans un vivre
ensemble aujourd'hui on est dans une
société et même si c'est liberticide et
même s'ils s'allient et moi s juin
je suis un peu tombé sur la ligne à
quelqu'un qui dit à matthew je sais pas
qui de se moucher ou de crash et mathieu
on va devoir laisser toucher et tu
reviendras précochée parce que des gens
disent que c'est insupportable
merci comme je jure c'est tout donc même
si on n'arrête pas de l'entendre ni
phénomène non mais c'est pour les
téléspectateurs il ya beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui dit à ses débuts le
temps ensemble
voilà étant mais il est quand même
valérie vous avez vu comme cette
mauvaise foi sans rigoler mais tout le
monde le voit tout l'été laisse pas gary
dit quoi c'est moi ou dans mes deux ans
mais bouge toi mon chéri tu reviens
juste après il ya pas de problème aux
régionales non j'ai ri et même si c'est
vrai qu'après mon changement 8h30 même
si c'est pesant même si c'est lourd et
effectivement c'est liberticide comme
l'a dit rené comme l'a dit valérie on
n'a pas le choix c'est un cas de force
majeure et moi je je trouve
j'en dis que si vous le permettez que la
petite ambiguïté dans ce que vous avez
dit et moi ce qui m'a profondément
choqué même si je suis pas là pour
donner des leçons aux démons points ou
des mauvais points
c'est qu'on vous dit je prends ma moto -
là aujourd'hui vous vous dites je vais
pas à vive allure mais je mène à une
certaine allure bon il sort de
l'ambiguïté et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
a instauré le continent pour justement
ne pas rouler à vive allure ou à moyenne
allure en tout cas ce qu'en faisant le
plus attention possible à ce que les
réal son plein et justement pourquoi
prendre le risque d'avoir des accidents
alors il ya le producer il ya le
producteur de gens lui qui me dit je te
garantis nous ne sommes pas vus avec
jean-luc depuis deux mois olivier kaki
may cry et on travaille que par facetime
c'est pas facile mais on respecte le
confinement donc voilà jean luc en tout
cas vous le rêve ou le respecter mais
jean luc chemin vous poser une question
moi moi je pense aussi et c'est ce que
j'ai dit hier jean-luc on ne connaît un
peu tu es toujours un peu rebelle est ce
que t'as pas voulu aussi titiller un peu
alors que toi qui est peut-être aussi
moi je te dis ne l'a été tu fais aussi
comme les bons élèves qui font leur
travail qu'ils font leurs trucs et qui
quand ils sont avec un pote on verse à
fond a dit wen en moi je m'en fous j'ai
rien appris je suis rien est ce que t'as
pas voulu un petit peu un oui parce que
c'était une c'était une interview que si
tu veux tu étais en vase clos
t'es sport tu t'es dit ouais ouais voilà
et là bon c'est vrai que je me suis un
peu lâché bon et ce alors qu'ils
stockaient c'est une expression jouant
très souvent d'ailleurs
la moto s'est excusé moi si mon mode de
locomotion à paris et c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment les avenues sont complètement
déserte et qu'on a tendance peut-être à
rouler un peu plus vite que batman font
pas ça mais évidemment faux pas mais que
voulez sur cantona mais bon au lieu de
rouler à 50 peut-être on a 70 80 que
c'est en avoir mais bon je m'arrête je
m'arrête pas au fait on bat sa main
droite assez d'accord avec moi sur ce
que j'ai dit à jean luc loe on a bien
peu ensemblier en moi je connais depuis
longtemps jean luc voilà je sais que
c'est pas un mauvais bougre et je sais
qu'il a dit ça parce qu'ils étaient
c'était un un tweet live je sais pas où
un style mais c'est vrai que bon il a
pas réduit forcément ça a été repris et
voilà bon moi je vous le dis honnêtement
il n'y a pas de quoi en faire tout un
fromage et en plus il n'a pas encouragé
les gens à ne pas respecter le
confinement s'agit pas du tout son
propos m
vraiment qu'on n'a pas entendu derrière
mon raymond merci beaucoup c'est vrai
que hocine concerne j'assume mes actes
quand je vais poster des conneries je
les assume jésus résumé mais là c'est
une situation vraiment terrible comme
disait rené où il y a des chaque jour
des familles qui sont dans le deuil et
je le déplore c'est dramatique c'est
j'ai ma soeur qui est infirmière
anesthésiste et chaque jour elle me fait
pas de 2,5 à la vue des personnes
qu'elle a vu dans la peine de cette
famille qui viennent on leur apprend que
c'est fini c'est terrible donc je le
plastique vraiment à faire attention je
suis moi même extrêmement prudent et
cyril se disait mon mode de vie leur
mode de vie extrêmement simple c'est pas
pour autant que je vais me lâcher dans
les rues et cetera je ne danse pas sur
les places de mon enfant je ne
m'arrêtera je je je suis extrêmement
prudent je préfère très au sérieux notre
voie vraiment un truc à dire mon chéri
moi je ne cautionne pas ce qu'il a dit
hier parce que on peut pas cautionner
évidemment le confinement ça embête tout
le monde il dit il a toujours été hors
glisse t il la fit cesser sauver 59 60
fois des maisons et tu t'endors peu moi
moi aussi je suis tout en dehors de 5
heures du matin jusqu'à 22h et malviès
est stoppé net de respectivement naim
benhaim aussi elles étaient deux ans
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin tous les soirs
en boîte de nuit 1
je te le dis dans mes films en voilà
mais on souffre tout le monde oui les
mecs qu'ils aient les mêmes à tout ça
tout ça c'est dur à vivre le confinement
à quelqu'un qui a pourtant l'habitude
est d'or il ya plein de gens qui ont
l'habitude d'être dehors tout le temps
du matin jusqu'au soir ils sont enfermés
chez eux c'est pour le bien de tous
c'est pour pas éviter d'encombrer les
les urgences et où es-tu dont moi je ne
cautionne pas ce qu'il dit mais en
revanche il ya un truc qu'il faut lui
reconnaître à jean-luc s'il est là ce
soir a parlé de ça c'est parce que ça a
fait un buzz parce que lui au moins il a
le courage et il a les couilles d'avoir
dit les choses en vrai parce qu'il ya
plein de people qui sort qui font plein
de trucs et on le sait pas past merci
merci réponse est sage a envoyé parce
que merci raymond keita tu oublies qui
ont comme toi dedans tu veux nantes est
en crypté un moment mais ça nous a fait
du bien ce que matthieu delormeau a eu
le temps de se moucher
matthieu delormeau ou non apparemment il
est toujours voilà il est temps il est
parti au sort
voilà donc il va revenir dans un instant
merci jean luc d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas
et là moi précisé tes propos louis-jean
lui je réitère ma proposition
tu sais que je suis président de mon
club de parachutisme frais toile château
dès que ça prendra on ne sait pas quand
est-ce que pour l'instant tous les clubs
de france et d'europe sont fermées bien
sûr le jour où ça ouvrira si l'un
d'entre vous a le courage plaisir de
venir sauter avec moi je le suis murray
en talent et en drame en moi je moi jean
luc si je peux faire un sou avec rené
malleville coûteux dire la cure à lise
mon rêve là franchement ils seraient
bienvenus
là je serai là je serais heureux bas
merci j'aurais dû avoir été avec la
mairie nous avoir expliqué ton propos et
d'avoir remis les choses au clair merci
jean luc